[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
like the video and comment here guides
at the end of episode 3 when the night
King was killed everyone was like that's
it what if I tell you that's not it what
if I tell you Jon Snow will get the
final kill when he kills brain Stark who
is the night king ending how stark that
just might be the final third holy SH
twists promised by the showrunners to
happen in season 8 and the promise
better satanic brain star character and
many other actors are quick to say big
no to the brain equal sniping theory in
many different interviews just like they
were quick to confirm jungles death at
the end of episode 5 and was not coming
back the thing I'm trying to say is if
the theory is not true they never say
yeah it's not gonna come true they say
maybe or I cannot tell you so it'd be
kind of betta to believe it might be
actually true and in reality it's not
but when something is correct when the
theory is right they'd usually say no
there's no way it's not happening like
when they all were saying jon was not
going to return in season 6 in all their
interviews just like then many actors
now including the one who plays brain
stark are quick to say big no and SD
brain is or will become the night king
my opinion it's a big hint that it might
actually come true at the end of episode
3 many denied King theories were
debunked one of those long hell theories
had to do with the fatal brain and the
theory that he and the knight King are
the same person
but season 8 episode 3 seemed to suggest
that's definitely not the case or did it
here's the problem if bran in the night
King were one in the same then brain
would have died the moment are you
killed the night King right well maybe
not here's why the theory could still be
true and the night king could even come
back before Game of Thrones airs its
finale here's what we know about the
night King's death in the long night our
kills the night king with Valyrian steel
dagger once intended to be used to kill
brain earlier in season 7 Petyr
Littlefinger Baelish gave the dagger to
brain but brain gifted it to Arya the
presumption here is that brain somehow
knew that area had to kill the night
king and needed the right weapon because
of the three-eyed Raven considering the
night King has been such a strong and
unbeatable force of evil for seven
seasons
watching car use a little assassin
trickery to take him out in a blink of
an eye fills a little anticlimactic it
couldn't be that easy could it gamma
turns the night king being the worst
threat Westeros was building up for
eight seasons and him dying in the first
major battle does seem a bit
underwhelming to say at the very least
but what if there's more going on what
meets the eye
if it was all part of some convoluted
plan orchestrated by brain then at least
it sort of makes sense
what it brings death is not predicated
on destruction of the night king what if
it's been building up to this point and
as the brain is the xix theories predict
brain is not only still in charge of
creating and/or becoming the night king
but he ends up orchestrating his own
death I know your brain must hurt at
this point but bear with me what his
theory basically says that in the
upcoming episodes brain being returned
he fully knows how to control his
abilities Brandel believe he can rewrite
history and try to prevent the night
king from ever reaching benefi that's
why he decides to go back and stop the
night king several times but fails every
time ending up fulfilling the timeline
circle and taking the identity of the
night king himself the first time he
tries to convince the mad king that
there are white walkers beyond the wall
and he's got to burn them all but brain
fails as the Mad King goes crazy from
the whispers and instead killed his
grandfather record and his uncle Brandon
and later tries to burn the city the
second time brain goes even beyond back
in time as he continues to learns his
abilities he's able to go longer and
longer back in time to try and find
another way of killing the night king
before he could ever become so powerful
he fells again and instead succeeds to
become bran the Builder building the
wall and securing his birth by building
men are failing creating the world's
there must always be a stark in
Manorville the last time brain goes back
all the way Verdun a king was created to
work into human the leader is going to
become the night king or maybe even try
to kill the children on the forest and
if they prevent from ever creating the
night King in the first place he works
into him to instead stop the journalist
into the heart event from happening or
even to try and convince the children
not to turn him into a white Walker
because they would ultimately become the
biggest threat so he fails and gets
chosen as the vessel for the night king
brain doesn't think of that the children
of the forest will not recognize him
from the future and the day at that
point are in the war with the first
man his gag because of all weird future
talk he realized he felt again he tries
to go back in the current timeline but
can because he's too deep into the past
and stayed long it's beautiful beneath
the sea stay too long and you drown from
here brain gets stuck in the past
exactly is Brighton and Georgian warned
him not to and becomes the night king
with the combination of the children's
magic and brands power he becomes the
villain instead of the hero he tried to
be resulting in turning against the
children for creating him and getting
stuck behind the magical wall he later
builds as brand builder immortal as he
is he waits for himself to be born
thousands of years later knowing when
and where he has to be to mark the young
brain personally kill the three-eyed
Raven for hiding the truth about what
would happen with him and eventually
being able to destroy the wall with
Viserion the knight King was brain and
he was marching south to kill an actual
brain so the brain doesn't go back and
become the night king because brain
going back is what made brain become the
night king you can eventually see in the
scene where young brain goes back the
creation of the night king that when the
children put the dragon once into his
heart we see brain tightens grip on his
veins just as it's himself experiencing
the pain also at the end of the
flashback brain is laying the exact same
position in the cave as the human pushed
up to the trees this theory also parts
we just know being the Prince promised
who eventually has to kill his little
brother brain giving us a bittersweet
ending after all we have been promised a
better seat ending John hood pledged his
life for how stark ending up killing its
last male heir to end the great war
would surely fulfill that bittersweet
ending better that John had to kill
brain stark but sweet that the true
night king is destroyed once and for all
and John has finally ended brains misery
I think brains playing the entire time
in episode 3 was to lead the night king
himself to kill his younger self and
prevent him from ever becoming tonight
King why else was brain working for so
long in my opinion he definitely was
leading the night king to himself when
the night King walked up to brain he
looked like he accepted his fate I just
feel like the night king his brain the
night king was going to kill brain to
destroy himself
was it really a coincidence that the
night king was killed by the same weapon
used on failed a time to kill brain I
mean the way the night king just looked
at brain it felt like he had to do it
he didn't want to are you ruining the
plans for brain what if that entire
senior he was working was actually him
leading the night king directly to where
he was in the forest to kill him and
stop him from ever becoming the night
king there's also a possibility that
this is not the case and brain actually
did not know he was the night king all
along but rather learns that in the
upcoming episodes in his visions the
brain realizes he was the night king all
along
maybe he'll head into the past by choice
and become the show's main antagonist
creating a sort of perfect time loop it
is possible at the Battle of NFL is both
the starting and ending point of brains
life as the night king in the moment the
night King dies brain begins a new
journey that will ultimately lead to him
either engineering the night Kings
creation or perhaps permanently warg
into his body in the past brain must
know that only he has the power to go
back and create the night king when the
three-eyed Raven says he will never walk
again but he will fly he means through
time and not only working a dragon or
Ravens like many fans believed there was
a reason Jorge Andrade who also had the
greenside and knew even more things
about it and brain did not become the
three-eyed Raven himself the reason is
that bran is even more powerful than
both the Jojen and the twitter raven
bryant and rivers in may that he is both
greenside and the ability to worry with
this combination brain is even able to
affect the past by working in tavella's
and eventually making him become horror
which proves dink is dry
he also gains his father's attention
outside the Tower of joy and even gets
touched by the night king in one of his
green sites he has also been warned at
using green site and working her
addicted
role he'll probably break out to ensure
the knighting is created by the children
of the forest the catches many fans have
predicted is that brain will become
stuck in the night King this would mean
that bran has the in theory always been
the night King much like the way time
travel works in Avengers and game human
brain is a version of his past and the
night king of the past was always
destined to brands future and final form
it might be a stretch but it would also
provide some actual resolution to brains
confusing plotline it would also give
fans a bit more closure on the sudden
death of the night king who was well you
know supposed to be the most evil thing
of all time turning brain into the night
king maybe the only way to wrap up both
of those loose
it's a once every just three episodes
left it's probably the best option I
just feel like the night king his brain
the 19 was going to kill brain to
destroy himself I mean the way the night
king just looked at brain it felt like
he had to do it when he did not want to
there's also a third possibility and it
also includes brain being the night king
some believe the night king was going to
give his sort brain and Neil just before
he was dead
Azra high is playing out his prophecy
preventing this but it may not be over
yet many still believe brain is the true
knight king brain start being denied
king is already a popular theory given
his role as the three-eyed Raven the
meeting of the two had the potential to
reveal that brain was the true knight
King but Arya killed the king before
that could never happen the theory goes
on to suggest that in an upcoming
episode we may see some alternate
reality play out in one of rains visions
where we see the night king Neil
to pass on whatever power and magic is
necessary to brain think about it brain
agreed for Thea know for people to
protect him this guy is not exactly
known for his consistent bravery and he
only had a handful of men by his side
that plane was never going to work and
brain knew it he also unnecessarily let
Fiona die trying to save him making sure
there were no witnesses to what was
about to go down between him and the
knight king in any way all those three
different theories and possibilities
include brain start being the real night
king or next in line night king and
he'll probably have to be killed by jon
snow does the promise better satanic
also entire brain stark denied king
think from episode three has to be
explained and turning brain into the
night king maybe the only way to wrap up
both of those loose threads at once as I
already said it might be a stretch but
this would also provide some actual
resolution to brains confusing plot line
as well as to the sudden death of the
night king in the bogus night's king was
a stark who was killed by his brother so
perhaps that's another hinder the last
male stark brain stark is or will become
the night king and I'll be killed by his
brother Jones now not only would it be
bittersweet that John had to kill brain
who is the true night king but it will
also be said that is John who has to end
how stark one suffer all by killing its
last male one last thing let's not
forget the explicit emphasis on Barry's
resurrection serving a purpose whereas
this has not been done explicitly yet
for John whose resurrection was a
significant blood point as well John was
resurrected for reason his father
Rhaegar left his wife and kids for Lena
for reason to create a Song of Ice and
Fire
the principles promise double defeating
al King once and for all and I believe
that unites King his brain Starkey and
John who had to kill him ending the
night King and how stark both please let
me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one peace